Dimmie you literally have the maturity
of a three-year-old all you do is talk
about yourself and all right Demi let's
get right into it Courtney attacked you
with a pacifier tonight will you be
filing the assault charges that you
mentioned no and she's lucky that I'm
not no I mean I it took her a long time
to come up with that idea so it was a
terrible idea is stupid but I don't have
the time a day to go and file an assault
charge against her she embarrassed
herself enough tonight and that was all
the pleasure I need about a man what was
going through her head when she was
coming at you because we were watching
it a little freaked out we didn't know
what she was gonna do her what she had
in her hand um I just thought maybe she
was like kind of like be a little sassy
or something and like the second she put
her hand at my phasic on him so I was
like ready to throw hands and I was like
this is not Jeffrey or what's the thing
Jerry Springer every star hi welcome
back to my channel I think this is not
Jerry Springer Dimmie do not throw hands
am just wondering where the pacifier
came from she seemed to have been
sitting on it and then she's out of her
butthole I don't know but I was just I
was triggered when she put that thing
near my face oh thank where'd you pull
that out of why are you putting it near
my face and where's the police security
security security please so that all
happened but overall I kinda feel like
you won tonight I mean like do you feel
like you won tonight I absolutely feel
like I'd won they were chanting Tammy
damn you like yeah this is my moment
[Music]